in my last book and beyond order i
talked a fair bit about harry potter and
yeah
a lot of the people who liked to take
pot shots at me took pot shots at that
because you know
i don't know they think harry potter's
beneath their notice or something but
you know i kind of noticed that jk
rowling made several billion dollars
building the biggest entertainment
enterprise of the decade and rose
herself from
you know single mother status uh
unemployed single mother status to
richer than the queen
and then occupied every movie screen for
like 10 years
maybe something's going on there yeah
well these complex
characters they play out mythology you
know and so
if religion disappears in the culture in
general it pops up in our stories
instantly and that's exactly what's
happened in the marvel universe and what
happened you even have thor for god's
sake thor is a god
yeah it's not even it's not even subtle
yeah
you can't get rid of these stories they
they come back no matter what you do
these stories come back
so what was what was jk rowling doing
with the with harry potter
well it's the battle between good and
evil i mean voldemort is satan for all
intents and purposes
yeah so it's it's it's the battle
between good and evil i mean the second
volume in particular is saint george and
the dragon it's bilbo and the dragon
harry fights a giant snake that's under
the castle it's the same story as the
lord of the rings
and that's the same story as as um
what's the original story
hobbit yeah but far before that
well the oldest story we have of that
sword is a mesopotamian creation myth
where a god named marta
attacks a giant dragon named tiamat
and that's one of the oldest religious
tracks that we have it's
symbolic of humanity right the human
being goes out there and encounters the
terrible unknown
often in reptilian form and that
well that's why that terrible unknown is
often evil itself and so in christianity
you get this weird intermingling
for example of the snake in the garden
of eden with satan
it's not obvious why there should be a
connection yeah you're a snake
safe yeah it's like well what's the
worst snake
it's not a snake it's snakes as such
well it's not snakes as such it's
predators
as such reptilian predators wait a
minute
it's not reptilian predators as such
it's enemies
it's human enemies it's the enemy in our
own soul
that's the progression of the thought
unbelievably sophisticated how does it
go from insanely sophisticated how does
it go from
enemies to the enemies in our in our own
soul well
who's your worst enemy if it's not you
who's your biggest obstacle if it's not
you
and who do you contend with more than
anyone else if it's not you
and to the harry potter thing harry
potter has a piece of voldemort
in him yes well that's that's the
original sin doctrine recreated
so it's also the case that he can't
understand evil without it it's also
part of what makes him sophisticated
right because he's being touched by it
yeah so is that what we got to do is
just copy the bible
like we don't have a choice wait what do
you mean by that
it happens whether we want it to or not
i mean the bible aggregated itself over
centuries
right i mean no human being directly
oriented that it it's not something that
could happen over thousands and
thousands
of years this is just the greatest hits
that's one way of thinking about it yes
and each one of these hits
taps into something innate to us
yes otherwise we wouldn't remember it
we wouldn't have we wouldn't have
conserved it it wouldn't stick in our
memory it wouldn't structure the way we
[Applause]
think